what was your favorite moment from ufc
gang gang gang baby and i think he means
270 probably yeah you're in the future
bro yeah
that was through dmt or mushrooms
like 271 who's he's not even announced
that look that guy was there apparently
it was a [ __ ] good time [ __ ] i wish
we should facetime him like who wasn't
ready man in that car
well for but but i can tell my favorite
moment from last night to 70
i definitely think when moreno woke up
that [ __ ] arena turned dude i've been
in
many years since and last night
when he woke up it was like i thought i
was in tijuana yeah i was like [ __ ] this
is a lot of [ __ ] mexicans here i was
like this is great like
you can feel like sometimes people make
noise but it almost feels like when
mcgregor will work out
you know
just when he woke up he's huge so he
feels like
pretty dense was there another great
moment from that that you enjoyed from
last night last night
yeah what do you think of that other uh
the i'm thinking of the moreno the
outcome
i
is
i hate when i know the guys because i
want them to win and if i was so close
i think
i think they could give it to him
but also
um
what's his name figueretto was being
smart on don't throw first
because he will be counter pretty easy
so he was almost waiting for big shots
and there was two different rounds if
i'm gonna run he touch him
and moreno went down i think one of them
wasn't a real
one one was a real knock down when he
put the choke and ten seconds left
that choke was fully sync so that was
really scary was he saved by the bell
you think there
maybe
i we have to say yes because he was like
he couldn't scramble now but it was
fully on and then
he ran out of time so that was a good
thing for miranda but then there was one
that he get touched with a job and he
went to the ground but it was more like
odd balance but we don't know that it
could be a real knockdown and then
i think the referee i think it was three
to two maybe because of that but moreno
put more and since i was there i saw
uh figuredo
pretty haired more than once like almost
ready to go down but i
i just feel like
mourinho was being very patient if you
if he were to step in the gas i think he
could finish him
and do you think that's something that
you learn as a fighter if you're in
there like not to like to be careful of
your counter punches like sometimes you
you learn like oh
when i counter or when i punch first
they're countering better like
especially the last fight like like uh
figure came pretty strong and mourinho
just countered him until he just took
him down and finish him and this time he
he wasn't that aggressive he was waiting
more from ren and those low kicks also
were pretty heavy
it was an exciting fight it was a great
last 20 seconds for they just said let's
go they went max
holloway llamas they point to the ground
say [ __ ] you
it was a great fight dude it was a great
fight
the whole crowd was bowing heavy so
if you if it would be a clean decision
then i don't think the crowd will boot
that bad
i i felt like that i felt like if it was
a ti i feel like they may should maybe
just made it a draw
exactly like they make the first time
like a draw would be great but
being a judge is a shitty job i i know
they sometimes like they make oh like
that wasn't
like that could go to moreno but
sometimes they make some decisions that
you're like which fight you were looking
like yeah like that but like the whole
world gets crazy on it yeah and
but being a judge is a cheater yeah but
none of those guys
are martial artists none of those guys
have a full background that's crazy
isn't it
most of the
there's one referee the one judge that i
got to talk to him and i asked him like
like where you came from like like right
what you know about mma he's like yeah
i'm a boxing referee i'm like
oh you're [ __ ] who isn't a boxing
referee yeah i'm like so everybody here
yeah like you have to separate no
headbutts and i guess no not big punches
and they're not clinching of course but
but that's just like crime like i feel
like if you go on trial for murder or
something
the people in the box should all be
murderers you know the jury
because at least then they're gonna be
able to be like oh yeah he did it or
didn't if you're getting somebody that
works at a bakery or something they
don't [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you